et
c'est un pic et subban essoufflé que
nous avons attrapé à la sortie de
l'aréna sportplexe à pierrefonds il
vient de passer une bonne heure sur la
glace avec ses nouveaux coéquipiers d'un
c'est vraiment cool expérience avec un
pro de la nature il nous a prédit la fin
comme quand on fait ça avec la rondelle
on a gardé notre école c'est ok you're
en herbe ont entre 8 et 14 ans certains
parmi eux sont venus de beauce ton pour
jouer avec piqué souben convient mariale
pour voir le cas de ce piquet
souviennent ses excellents on est
tellement excités ont visité la femme
est au même point
joindre l'utile à l'agréable c'est aussi
la motivation de piquer subban et même
s'ils n'osent plus le maillot 76 des
canadiens il continue à s'engager pour
la fondation de l'hôpital de montréal
pour enfants
[Applaudissements]
comment monsieur sort des besoins et
pour venir en aide aux enfants malades
chaque participant a déboursé la somme
de 376 $ pour deux journées
d'entraînement
c'est en 2015 que piquet subban a
commencé à récolter des fonds pour
l'hôpital
il s'est engagé à verser 10 millions de
dollars sur sept ans aujourd'hui il
atteint 30 % de son objectif
ce geste de philanthropique et subban il
explique aussi par l'attachement qu'il a
pour montréal entre piqué soudain et les
montréalais c'est une belle histoire qui
dure
et aujourd'hui sur la glace froide les
coeurs été chaud ici à smic rails at
radio canada montréal